what is machine learning hello my name
is Richard Kirchner I'm with the simply
learned team that's WW simply learned
calm kids certified get ahead today
we're covering what is machine learning
what's in it for you we're gonna cover
the basics of machine learning what is
machine learning artificial intelligence
versus machine learning versus deep
learning how does machine learning work
types of machine learning machine
learning pre-requisite s-- applications
of machine learning here we have our
looks a little bit like Frankenstein or
Frankenstein looking robot today let me
tell you what is machine learning
machine learning works on the
development of computer programs that
can access data and use it to
automatically learn and improve from
experience watch a robot builder
construct house in two days this was
back in July 29th 2016 so that's pretty
impressive this amount of time to
continue to grow in his development and
it's smart enough to leave spaces in the
brickwork for wiring and plumbing and
can even cut and shaped bricks to size
Amazon echo relies on machine learning
and with more data it becomes more
accurate play your favorite music order
pizza from dominos voice control your
home request rides from uber have you
ever wondered the difference between AI
machine learning and deep learning
artificial intelligence a technique
which enables machines to mimic human
behavior this is really important
because this is how we are able to gauge
how well our computations or what we're
working on works is the fact that we're
mimicking human behavior we're using
this to replace human work and make it
more efficient and make it more
streamlined and more accurate and so the
center of artificial intelligence is the
big picture of all this put together
IBM deep blue chess electronic game
characters those are just a couple
examples of artificial intelligence
machine learning a technique which uses
statistical methods enabling machines to
learn from their past data so this means
if you have your input from last time
and you have your answer
you use that to help prove the next
guess it makes for
correct answer I'd be at Watson Google
search algorithm email spam filters
these are all part of machine learning
and then deep learning which is a subset
of machine learning composing algorithms
and allow a model to train itself and
perform tasks alphago natural speech
recognition these are a couple examples
deep learning is associated with tools
like neural networks
where's kind of a black box as it learns
it changes all these things that are as
a human we'd have a very hard time
tracking and it's able to come up with
an answer from that now let's see how
machine learning works first we start
with training the data once we've
trained the data the Train we go into
the machine learning algorithm which
then puts the data into a processing
which then goes down to machine another
machine learning algorithm and then we
take new data because you have to test
whatever you did and make sure it works
correctly and we put that into the same
algorithm once we do that we check our
prediction we check our results and from
the prediction if we've set aside some
training data and we find that it didn't
do a good job predicting it and it gets
a thumbs down as you see then we go back
to the beginning and we retrain the
algorithm and a lot of times it's not
just about getting the wrong answer it's
about continually trying to get a better
answer
so you'll see the first time you might
be like oh this is not the answer I want
depending what domain you're working in
whether it's medical
economical business stocks whatever you
try out your model and if it's not
giving you a good answer you retrain it
if you think you can get a better answer
you retrain it and you keep doing that
until you the best answer you can let's
see the types of machine learning
supervised learning unsupervised
learning there's a number of ways to
divide up machine learning and how it
works these are two main categories you
can divide it into supervised learning
we have a known amount of data so in
this case we have a bunch of apples we
have a machine learning algorithm it
goes through the process it goes through
and trains a model based on that knowing
data and then once you've trained your
model on the knowing stuff either you
can then put an unknowing data in there
and you get a new response and of course
in this particular one it's an apple so
it's trying to figure out whether it's
an apple or another fruit there are many
different algorithms you can use for
computing this information for doing
this
provides training just to list the some
of the top ones that are currently being
used and by no means not there's more
than just this so by no means this isn't
the complete list
there's polynomial regression there is a
random forest there's linear regression
there's logistic regression there's
decision trees there's K nearest
neighbors and there's naive Bayes like I
said this is just a short list of some
of the many tools that are out there
nowadays and if you have supervised
learning then we should also look at
unsupervised learning unsupervised
learning so we have unknown data in this
case you can see we have a bunch of
fruit and we might not have labeled it
we don't know we've never had anybody
look at it and say this is what this is
and we take that data and we put it
through the machine learning algorithm
and then that goes through the
processing and then the trained model
and with the trained model says hey can
I see a pattern here
and from that pattern it divides it up
into a response in this case apples and
pears you can see some of these things
look just like the other and it tries to
put them all together so that you get
similar things in similar groups and
again we have a nice list of algorithms
here and this is not the only algorithms
used for this so don't let me yourself
to this just these these are just some
of the primary ones used today and of
course we have the k-means clustering
singular value decomposition fuzzy means
partial least squares a priori
hierarchical clustering principal
component analysis machine learning
prerequisites computer science
fundamentals and programming so any of
the machine learning out today you have
to know some basic scripting or
programming intermediate statistical
knowledge you have to understand a
little bit about probabilities if a is
current how likely is B going to happen
if there's clouds overhead how off like
Li is it going to rain linear algebra
and intermediate calculus the linear
algebra is very important because you
have to understand basically drawing a
line through the data points and what
that means that's the most fundamental
linear regression models you draw a line
through all your data and you use that
line to compute new values intermedia
calculus means you need to have a little
bit of understanding of what a
differential equation is really don't
need to be an expert because the
computer does all the heavy lifting for
you but it's important to know the terms
when they come up unless
doing some advanced programming on the
actual models themselves and data
wrangling and cleaning I would say this
might be the biggest one in here is you
have to start getting a grip on how to
clean up your data there's a saying is
bad data in bad data out good data in
you're more likely to have good data out
some applications of machine learning
instance segmentation object detection
instant segmentation you can see here
where they use machine learning to go in
there and find where the different cats
are and the different objects are in the
picture and then in segmentation it
actually cuts them out kind of a fun one
especially if you have a Google pixel
phone and you can do a little animation
objects on top of your ongoing pictures
you're taking her movies number plate
detection you can see here where we have
a car that comes in there and it finds a
number plate on the car once it's done
that it can then do automatic
translation automatic translation as we
pick up some symbols in this case on a
machine and it does machine translation
so that you can know what it's saying
even if you don't speak that language so
in summary we covered the basics of
machine learning what is machine
learning
we talked a little bit about the process
or the workflow of machine learning
we've looked at two different divisions
of some machine learning supervised and
unsupervised we went over the
prerequisites you should have going into
machine learning then you should have
the basic fundamentals or a little bit
of computer science and programming or
scripting skills you should know some
basic linear algebra and maybe it's a
little bit of calculus and differential
equations as part of the calculus you
should have some basic intermediate
statistical knowledge of what that means
and what those terminology means and you
should have an idea of what data
wrangling and cleaning is how do you
take your data coming in making sure you
don't have missing values make sure that
you're switching float values so they're
processed correctly integer values
versus something that's categorically
like yes true yes/no true/false and then
we looked at a couple applications of
machine learning of course there are so
many applications out in today's market
it's one of the biggest growing markets
out there this is just a very brief
summary of some of the things that are
going on again thank you for joining us
today for more information visit
www.gfi.com/webmonitor
any of this material or like more
information you can either post a
response down below the video or feel
free to visit WWF you learn comm hi
there
if you like this video subscribe to the
simply learn youtube channel and click
here to watch similar videos de nerd up
and get certified click here